three US states held primary elections
in the face of the corona virus outbreak
and Democratic voters gave Joe Biden a
clean sweep CBS News projects the former
vice president beat senator Bernie
Sanders in Florida Illinois and Arizona
that gives Biden a commanding lead in
delegates who will choose the Democratic
nominee ed O'Keefe is covering campaign
2020 and how does last night's outcome
change the race if at all
good morning Anthony Biden now has more
than half of the 1991 delegates needed
to clinch the Democratic nomination the
former vice president beat Sanders by
double digits in all three states his
strong showing last night is the latest
in a string of victories especially in
large states that could decide the
general election with such a large lead
the former vice president used brief
remarks from his Delaware home last
night to extend an olive branch to
Sanders supporters I hear you I know
it's at stake I know what we have to do
our goal is a campaign and my goal as a
candidate for president is to unify this
party and then to unify the nation
concerns about the coronavirus did
impact in-person voting especially in
Illinois about 200 voting sites in
Chicago had to be relocated after at
least 850 poll workers many of them
elderly stayed home due to health
concerns but increases in early voting
and mail-in voting pushed turnout in
Florida and Arizona above their 2016
levels Ohio had been scheduled to vote
but it's one of five states so far that
have rescheduled contests the Democratic
National Committee is urging states that
have yet to hold primaries to instead
allow all voters to vote by mail or use
absentee ballots Gail's right ed we're
still in the middle of a big campaign
thank you very much